good morning to you good evening to me
mark would sup nothing much
ken Mathew G welcome back that in the
saying egg did you say that before
and cheesy cheese actually I made eggs
earlier today with cheese twitch a can
very well predicts what food I I've had
or guess what food I've had I should say
hey it's Bob Andy with bits stoked
because I couldn't watch you earlier I
feel like you were there earlier but
maybe you just you passed by thanks for
returning Oh upon your playing so my
most recent Youtube upload was this line
I play this against Christopher you i
showed like all my preparation we'll see
I'll see how well-prepared white is yeah
so the idea is 95 and then B 5 and then
I force a main move an IG 4 and then
there's a few moves for white actually a
3 might be a move here III hear ya a 3
and F for the two main moves but White's
already thinking so that's a good sign
yeah getting the same position whoever
what with saw my in my most recent
YouTube video or saw my stream from what
was it last week yeah I had this exact
position against risk for you the game
went takes takes takes takes always
playing be one it takes 9f5 always
played I should I fades and I was all
prep but this is three Oh blitz so
appointment doesn't have too much time
to to think to calculate
if I guess the flight moves the night I
just take there should be seven rook c8
enjoy the bishop hair enjoy the long
diagonal threats along the C file ooh
neither five immediately a novelty
probably not too impressive though
because I can take and then take care um
still have to be careful but I mean this
is exactly the same position we would
have got except I have a pawn enough six
no pawn enough six it would be it would
be my game against Christopher you so
this has to help me because in the
Christopher you game Queen d4 attacked
the rook in this case Paul and keeps me
more safe usually what black wants is to
put the bishop on d5 hmm this move is
interesting because if I take then takes
and it's check I have Bishop c5 here I
have rook c8 as well
kind of like rook c8
because if takes and I just meet rook t2
maybe expected 52 hmm so I can take the
bishop in Bishop c5 still makes sense
and d5 is in the air hmm
there's some like takes like Bishop C
let's start with Bishop c5 I'll probably
take in King f8 looks logical like g7
Wow
but I have this move Queen g3 rookie
aides or queen g3 I just take a bishop
yeah why has too many things attacked
hey it's a Sode banana party hey banana
party it's a time on earth
it's a very thoroughly prepared time oh
yeah my opponent did not see my most
recent Youtube upload because white
should really avoid this line with like
after before it's already better for
black I was nice will that go on YouTube
- I was like a sequel actually right
before I started the stream I I began
uploading my my Ron for game from the
may chest mayhem against Gawain Jones
and it's a large file because I included
more Ben commentary but maybe what I'll
do maybe I'll upload this game tomorrow
because it's very timely given that
given that I had the Christopher you
upload earlier today yeah so people on
YouTube hope you enjoyed that
study your openings and don't get out
prepped